la foire de tour donc qui est sur le
podium des foires de France par sa
fréquentation derrière Paris et
Marseille un tour de force reproduit
chaque année depuis longtemps on en est
à la 102e édition après l'année de la
relance en 2022 et c'est plus de 300000
visiteurs cette année était-elle celle
de la confirmation on en parle avec mon
invité Jérôme Agnès bonjour bonjour
Michael vous êtes le directeur donc de
Tours événement l'organisateur de cette
fois alors est-ce que la fréquentation
pour ce premier week-end est à la
hauteur de vos attentes et bien écoutez
j'ai envie de vous répondre que la foire
de Tours est une centenaire et que cette
centenaire se porte très très bien
puisque oui nous avons eu voilà des
records de fréquentation enregistrées
sur ce premier week-end d'ouverture
combien
alors où je vous parle 210 000 entrées
sur le lundi inclus donc depuis
l'ouverture vendredi et nous avons battu
coup sur coup des records de
fréquentation quotidienne et notamment
pratiquement 70 000 visiteurs sur la
journée du dimanche qui est colossal et
jamais à la foire de tour de mémoire
d'exposants j'ai pu aujourd'hui en fait
prendre le pouls des autres ans voilà
après après ce premier week-end
d'activité pleine et de mémoire
d'exposants il y a jamais il l'avait
vécu un tel démarrage d'accord les la
fréquentation de plus de 300 000 de 2022
ou 2019 sera largement battu a priori
alors on le souhaite on l'espère tous
voilà l'essentiel n'est pas n'est pas
tant dans le dans le dans les records de
visiteurs etc le l'essentiel est bien
entendu que nos exposants travaillent et
que voilà les les clients qui se
présentent à eux puissent faire des
bonnes affaires parce que la foire de
tour est avant tout un événement
commercial le plus grand événement
commercial en région Centre et ouais
cette année ça plus de 500 500 exposants
pratiquement 500 exposants une
cinquantaine de plus qu'en 2022 une
cinquantaine de plus en 2022 ce qui est
un signe dans un premier temps de
confiance et également de toujours
d'attractivité de du produit fort de
tour la foire de tour est un une fois
centenaire qui est profondément ancrée
dans le dans le patrimoine coronjo dans
le cœur des tours en jour on le voit sur
les le visiteurs enregistré sur ce
premier week-end mais également sur le
nombre d'exposants qui répondent présent
dès lors qu'on ouvre nos espaces à la
commercialisation donc on oublie les
années les années covid il y a malgré
tout cette cette menace de l'inflation
et du portefeuille des Français qui est
un peu moins fourni qu'avant est-ce que
ça s'est ressenti sur les premiers jours
alors là encore aujourd'hui les les
retours que nous pouvons avoir de la
part de l'ensemble des exposants c'est à
ce sont des premiers jours qui ont été
travaillés voilà donc ça veut dire donc
les amandes et l'humour qui achètent des
armes du moins des bonnes affaires
du conseil de l'expertise car même si le
l'achat ne se comprise pas ce contexte
pas pardon sur place il peut se faire
voilà après je vous rappelle la foire
étant d'entrée gratuite donc le visiteur
voilà tout loisir de venir voilà prendre
des renseignements pousser sa réflexion
et revenir un petit peu plus tard dans
la semaine vous faites bien de le dire
c'est l'événement un événement gratuit
populaire 10 jours
qu'imaginez-vous pour les années à venir
est-ce que le format de la foire restera
identique ou alors ce que ce vous
prévoyez des aménagements à la marge
alors c'est ce que je vous disais en
préambule la fois la fois récentenaire
néanmoins la foire comme toute
centenaire et là voilà le droit de vivre
avec avec son époque et bien entendu de
vivre avec son temps donc les
aménagements futurs ils seront peut-être
à la marge dans ces voilà prochaine
année néanmoins on suivra toujours
l'actualité de ce qu'il se fait car la
foire c'est une place de marché elle est
là également pour mettre en avant les
dernières technologies les dernières
tendances et nous en tant
qu'organisateur on serait effectivement
très attentif à celle-ci la Corée du
succès le pavillon de la Corée
un énorme succès une énorme succès ça
fait comment dire depuis 10 ans on a
voyagé en Europe en Amérique en Afrique
on avait la volonté cette année de faire
découvrir l'Asie on a donc travaillé
avec en collaboration avec les relations
internationales de voilà de la ville de
Tours et puis on a eu l'information que
la ville de Tours était une ville amie
d'une ville en Corée du Sud nommée Swan
donc le lien s'est fait le lien s'est
fait très très naturellement avec un
fort voilà niveau patrimonial au niveau
technologies au niveau développement
durable donc on a pu proposer voilà une
une richesse d'animation qui rencontre
un réel succès on sait déjà qui sera le
pays invitait l'année prochaine oui on
le sait déjà parce que le le ça se
travaille très longtemps à l'avance
après ça reste encore un petit peu voilà
ça se dit plus tard ça se dira plus tard
et bon ben j'ai relaniel merci beaucoup
vous nous le direz donc
plus tard sur ce plateau merci merci
beaucoup merci à vous